now it's my real great pleasure to
introduce dr. nope naomi has really the
only is the chair and CEO of the as
reality foundation and I knew we were
going to hit it off because she asked a
PhD in neuroscience from Oxford oh now
you tell me she has a PhD from Oxford ok
two other three one of the great
pleasures of this our new relationship
between see far and the ass really
foundation has been for me at least the
opportunity to get Naomi to get to know
Naomi a little bit and I've got to learn
that as befits the head of I think a
major philanthropic organization naomi
is thoughtful the only a strategic and
she truly cares about making a
difference but she's also not afraid to
take risks I think another area where
see far and the ass reality foundation
have something in common so please join
me in welcoming Naomi sdlc
thank you so much Alan for your kind
introduction and for the wonderful
remarks I'm really thrilled to be here
this evening to see so many friends old
friends and new friends to be in this
beautiful space on this beautiful
evening I'm thrilled that most of the
directors on my border here and I'd like
to recognize them may of my colleagues
who worked hard to get to this day and
also my family my kids and my husband
pascua and my beautiful and wise mother
Stephanie who's sitting right there I'm
really really thrilled and I know that I
speak for all of us in the larger as
really family the foundation to say how
excited we are to be here this evening
to be partnering in this way and how
much we're looking forward to this
wonderful wonderful event at the Israeli
foundation we believe that research into
the brain is the final frontier of
science and that researchers in this
field are pioneers into one of the most
important areas there is in fact the
foundation has a long history of
supporting brain research through our
azrieli neurodevelopmental research
program we've partnered with the
canadian government and brain canada to
support research into autism fragile x
syndrome and other neurodevelopmental
disorders we also created the israeli
national institute for human brain
imaging and research in israel with the
Weitzman Institute and multiple other
partners and for at least a decade we've
been supporting scores of researchers
doctor'll postdoc early career and
senior scientists with research
fellowships our commitment to this area
comes from our recognition of
really an incredible fact and that is
that one of the biggest mysteries in the
universe is in your heads we still know
surprisingly little about the human
brain other than it is the most complex
structure in the known universe and
apparently even cosmologists agree to
that and we certainly don't know how
this complex structure generates
conscious self awareness so many
questions remain unanswered about how
the brain develops how it works how we
can intervene when it fails to work
properly and none are more important
more fundamental than the question of
consciousness why do we have it where
does it come from why does it feel like
something actually to be alive right
here right now on this evening in this
room in setting out to answer these
questions these and other questions we
are convinced that this new program will
help to illuminate many other
fundamental questions about how our
brains operate and how we can treat them
effectively when they don't I'm truly
delighted and honored that we are able
to partner with an institution like CFR
and indeed I feel that we are a great
fit for one another we found each other
at a very particular moment in our
evolution and in your evolution and
there was that click that doesn't always
happen and I'm thrilled that it has like
the azrieli foundation CFR is a
visionary institution that understands
the importance of undertaking high-risk
high-reward research they are interested
in pursuing fundamental questions but
always with an eye on the implications
those questions will have for improving
the world and see far like us has an
unswerving focus on excellence as the
truly exceptional co-directors of our
new program male good oh and adrian owen
and the many excellent people that are
now in this new program
as that as they can attest our
foundation shears would see far the
belief that investing in the best people
pays off and so as this wonderful
evening gets underway I'm going to end
with our hope and our belief that the as
really program in brain mind and
consciousness can answer important and
fundamental questions that will help us
understand ourselves and the world and
also make the world a better place I'm
thrilled to be here for to make this
donation to make this announcement of
this donation with you and I look
forward to a long and productive
relationship with CFR thank you